all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 27 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
as most of you already aware the iron
Lords podcast is now part of the inner
circle Network and we are very excited
moving forward this great partnership so
shout out to Almighty icgn
family but I'm also very excited about
our special guest so we gotta get right
into it I want to introduce a Lord whose
content I follow for a long time I
finally had the pleasure to meet this
Lord in the flesh at Bethesda press
conference
III 2016 he always brings positive
energy to everything he does and even if
he rubs someone the wrong way with his
opinion he's always open to a civil
debate it might even put that
championship belt on the show he is an
ambassador for two prominent community
gaming and of course hip hop on your hot
9 7 every day that's my word I need a
drum roll y'all interview was in the
game the creator of shots fired super
nintendo sega genesis was dead broke and
couldn't picture this mob me lord
hip-hop how are we doing sir you know
that was dieters intro I've ever had in
my life sir I feel like I just came all
sways universe or so man I really really
humbly I'm just humbled man that's that
was incredible thank you so much for
that I really really appreciate that to
realtalk no I appreciate you bro we for
a long time you've known you for a while
and it was only doing for you to be on
at the round table with the lords and
you know we respect you a lot
so we had to boil T's in a building we
had to show that proper respect
you know they so we gonna get into it
thank you thank you sir thank you man
that's crazy
No
now and of course we have the usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother and how young wolf
mommy
Lord addict how're you doing sir pretty
good man I definitely want to take the
time out to thank hip-hop for coming on
the show again it's always nice to have
someone with this statue on the show
it's always respectful much love wow
thanks man wow man it's overwhelming
right now go Thank You Man love down
here bro you loved it of course our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single-player experience
semi offline ps4 pro Illuminati my lord
sovereign how we doing sir doing
fantastic man great great great
just just watch that lord of the better
game of Thrones episode and of course
the access game oh the Lord who is a man
of his convictions and demands nothing
less than the premium experience include
no special meal Oh Joe fantastic your
hip-hop I told you and of course it is
Lord cognero here spreading that gaming
Renison an ILP not telling you what you
want to hear or what you need so before
we get into it I want to go to what the
Lords of play in I want to start off
with Lord hip-hop's this video game
system history
despite a hip-hop game a channel the
belt in the movement so let's take it
back to the history hip-hop like your
video game system it was the first one
really like if the history is my
grandmother you know saying she's the
one who introduced me to video games so
I grew up in Co Brooklyn and you know I
came up in the 80s so that's the point
where you walk down the block his number
crack on the floor but it's like
everywhere is like it was really that
crazy so my grandmother you know keeping
me off the streets keep me off the
streets and stuff she introduced me to
gaming so the very first game I ever
played was miss pac-man on Atari 2600
so that's what got me started in gaming
and then when I play Super Mario
Brothers and to know you know a bit on
when I play that for the first time
that's when I knew I was the game of
life so it's cuz uh you know Mario shut
up - Miyamoto like says you don't saying
that's what got me like really really
hooked on gaming so you know fast
forward to now um I was watching an
episode of g4 TV years back a big thing
yeah I'm a big fan of you know what
you're talking about right now so my
thing is where um so I was watching an
obsessed something big fan of his and on
this particular episode it just felt so
this episode just felt real fake to me
like you know how this when you watching
somebody you know that's like it ks1
came out with a whole album talking
about like mumble rapping it's like
that's not you dog you know say so so
like I know I'm if it was like a home it
was like a Christmas episode but he was
doing like a game of the year and I'll I
forgot what his game of the year was put
his reasoning and everything just didn't
feel natural felt like he had to say
that the draws themselves were nothing
wrong and that way they feel brew so um
I was like yeah I gotta talk about this
so that's when I started you know my
youtube channel you know hip-hop gamer
the reason why is because I'm a big fan
of hip-hop and I'm an artist myself and
I've been gaming all my life so my life
was based around hip-hop and gaming so
it just made sense that I'd come up with
an
that was authentic to who I was as a
person you understand so wow that's
that's how that you know came about so I
made a video and you know it was you
know it was pretty good in terms of the
perception that I got based on what I
said it didn't look good but it didn't
look great but I didn't care
felt like I felt like my value was in
what I said not the way the video look
so awesome
so then uh my man Torrence Davis who've
been going to e3 for years and years and
years um he discovered me you know long
story short he discovered me and I got a
chance to go to e3 in 2008 cousin him
and when I went to India 2008 I did some
of the biggest interviews ever my first
year and I'm one of those where Aaron
Greenberg my man my song singing that's
my dude oh that was back when we had the
blu-ray vs. HD DVD bad news and stuff
like that you know it was crazy
so I did some of the best interviews
that like the industry has ever seen
it was one of those situations where
honestly real talk it's like how does
[ __ ] with the film able to do this
that's the way did it like before they
respected it they was like how did he do
that you know that's when a lot of
controversies and they started to build
up but that's what got me in the door
you know just my passion and my love and
my humbleness you know and respect for
you know the game industry the people in
it and my love for a gaming period
overall in terms of the culture so
that's like a little backstory on the
name and how everything came about and
what led me to get know like in the
industry so that you know that's pretty
much that right there and everything
else is the rest is history just being
consistent um building more partnerships
with companies outside of gaming and
growing that way it's well nice now tell
me about to tell because I'm always
curious how that started in like it's
funny because we sort of reacts a almost
offering to be X minus IPX stand up no
doubt so we used to do that with the
belt like we used to do tournaments with
like the
sovereign more Chi box with a lock on
all those guys like we used to literally
we bought WCW don't we so whoever win
this week go tall with the belt so when
we see I see you do so what else thought
it is you know he is like a whole yeah
like your origin with the whole thing
how did you know God she so those two
things um so one my grandmother has
always been a champion in my life like
for those that don't know I never met my
mom's you don't say I don't know her she
left when I was 2 years old so I never
met my mother and my father
you know um growing up we had the best
relationship but you know my father was
a gangster you know I'm saying he'll
talk so um like we didn't always have
the best relationship but he got me he
he's the reason why I got my tough side
you understand I'm saying so but my
grandmother was my everything but she
raised me did everything so when you
talked about that I remember that
episode yeah so my grandmother is the
you know saying so because she's the
reason why I do what I do I wanted to
have something that symbolize me being
the best at what I do so being the best
means you're a champion so it has a
double meaning me being the best at what
I do as a champion and me um honoring my
grandmother as being a champion in my
life you understand I'm saying so that's
what the bill represents just taking
everything that I love and putting it on
his title to represent myself and also
represent my grandma and also represent
the gaming industry hip hop industry
everything that I'm a part of as being
the once I'm involved you know the best
is here you already know grandma because
at the end of the day like I said she
inspired you and we like I said the
content she doing it all comes from the
heart is passionate and we respect that
and one last question I had to ask you
and obviously from
city you know the Lord's most of us yeah
you know we all grew up on that hotline
seven so they're appreciative of that
partnership and I always respected you
for that because like to me when I saw
you made a move on my that's crazy
see when I was trying to talk to a lot
of companies especially hot 97 because
high 97 that's the first station they
ever started playing hip-hop so it's not
all about
let me just find the best deal I needed
he said I needed to work with them
specifically because of what they stood
for what the brand mitts of the culture
and being the first and when you're the
first [ __ ] of when you're the first year
forever but in this situation they do it
better period so I had the rock with
them so in 2014 I believe um Randi
Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg sister huh
and some other people was putting
together this event for this Facebook
game called Giggy
and he have across and 2 Chainz and Nas
and everybody come out yeah everybody
came out so I got a chance to meet Peter
Rosenberg and um he blowing all that on
a very carpet I was doing coverage and
me and Peter Rosenberg we didn't do a
long interview but the interview was
damn good it was a real good interview
and his publicist gave me a car I wanted
to keep in contact because we wanted to
do more on the subject matter that we
did an interview on to extend it and I
was talking to her like yo like anybody
that's in the world of entertainment
that's not utilizing gaming is losing
it's like trying to be a social media
star but you don't have Instagram
Facebook or YouTube what are you doing
so um so my thing is I was explaining to
them and telling them about how gaming
can be very lucrative in the growth of
hot 97 cuz you're number one here so
there's nowhere else to go you're just
gonna kind of be doing the same thing in
the same space you got to find other
territories to take over like you did in
hip hop so I'm the person that brings
all that says authenticity
in a cosign for hot 97 to be look take
seriously in this medium you understand
so we had a long conversation and I'll
you know have one meeting after one
meeting that deal was done so um so once
that happened we was just talking about
how he was gonna execute the plan but
behind the scenes there was a lot of
people that was in certain positions
that people got hired people got fired
things got changed he had a that he had
to read acquaint yourself with new
people that was in the position that it
was just a lot of policy stuff that's in
place that delayed a lot of things but
you know God is never late he's always
on time so you know we never worried
about that so um once certain things got
into place we was able to make it happen
and now you know the partnership is
stronger than ever and there's other
things going on behind the scenes that
provide this in October mmm
y'all gonna see something so big we're
hip hop hot 97 and one of the biggest
tech companies in the world come
together okay and I'm the face of it oh
you see my headphones yeah yeah
exclusive y'all we saw loves doing so
states oh man I'm telling is gonna be
big man so you know I'm just proud of
hot 97 giving me the opportunity to do
this and not overlook it like it's just
you know some random gaming thing nah
they took it seriously and they allowing
me to lead that charge so it's going
down for real that's what some facts man
appreciate you dropping that little gem
on us I'm in the chat we got 33 in check
I'll make sure y'all hit that like and
one of the people in the chest said they
like that hat he must be a falcon space
so he's awesome rise up right now I'm a
michael vick van play his but i don't
like uh from a personal standpoint I
don't like Michael Vick's views on the
whole thing in I feel like Michael
Vickers are cool for that bra but it's
also just play skill like his skill
level in things he did on a field he's
incredible as a football player so
you know that's why I had the Falcons
hat on and you don't read this one my
favorite colors made black red and white
Chicago Bulls deadest yeah that's what's
up man I appreciate that
we all remember Vic's mad in ratings
magnet baby say that in everything real
quick what the Lord's been playing this
week so um let's start off with my
co-host Lord addict which you've been
rocking this week man with engagement
plan I've been pretty much playing The
Escapist - and that's you own sunset
over Germany okay I'm just looking
forward to their credit I guess I'm more
towards like a serious aspect of the
game and you know it's definitely not a
serious aspect but you know I will say
that you know I used to say I just was
not billing this guy oh didn't like the
way it looked but actually putting a
like 1015 hours you know it's a good
game it's just I like more serious tone
games guys so you need to play mafia 3
I'm blazing the sonic mania on the
switch like really really get into that
sonic you know so I can I get my Sega
car back since it was taken out and then
I've been playing the Uncharted the
rundown
issues a mr. Li not withstand autumn
roll early early leave it at them
allegedly Oh Oh my ended the Sonic mania
greatest Sonic game made period and um
playing Mass Effect Andromeda Wow yeah
because you know everybody said all this
stuff about this I didn't pick it up at
launch and they said they catched it up
and I started playing it now so I'm
gonna give this gamers do because I'm a
mass effects do story wise how is going
is I like how the stories Nora I can't
front
um aesthetics wise when they have they
helmets on Oh beautiful baby
HDR looks fantastic the game plays nice
there's not too much of a departure is
an extension when you go land on world
explorations
all the stuff that we crave for we acts
what we got it it was fantastic so I'm
like okay so I start the dialogue it
looks like he's on his annex like he has
a kid lazy eyes he's not looking at me
anything he's all disinterested and it
separates you I feel a disconnect right
there cuz all we used to wait for the
dialogue tree listen intently and
everything that's the one aspect I see
they try to fix it because I soon before
and after so I said man the only thing
they have to do is take off the eye line
on do
the best effect did our syndrome right
there um but other than that I
understand why went from one engine to
the Frostbite engine and they're
learning things over again so in its the
B team is back baby so hopefully we get
that Mass Effect Andromeda too that we
deserve I do want to know what it did
that I do want to get I know this about
to be brought up
Iko do not encourage lower Kings
behavior okay he said we got hate Evo's
because of you last week if anybody's
not buying a meatball don't shortchange
yourself in its life you debt you
definitely need that a premium
experience if you have a switch it's a
premium experience it takes your switch
game to the next level you got that
money look I did here this week it's
better where we got mrs. arm still
August's hashtag kill the backlog mom
for me I'm a big destiny fan so I know
what's destiny come on September it's
gonna be hard for me so I'm actually um
I picked up a good one in the backlog
you know what I played um transformers
devastation oh I slept on this game like
if you're a fan of g1 hip-hop like like
transformers g1 with the old optimist Oh
devastated the art style is so yo dis
game is beautiful and I'm sitting it and
I was like I was happy but I was sags
I'm like I was just thinking about
scalebound you know cuz it's such a
stylish action game you know I'm saying
with the Autobots and stuff like that
and graphically yeah so it's just like
it really hit my heart like what
would've what could have been you know
me as far as you don't scale by on the
stuff but um absolutely very good power
point guard apps absolutely
Oh what's up attic you definitely should
go in there about your little vendetta
you got with that achievement system
because you get a little out of control
right now man I think I think I might
have to you know there gotta be some
kind of help for people like you from
your place that might borrow right I got
this Mike Vargas I'm trying to win
August achievements August in extra tax
buying these easy achievement games
trying to creep up on my scar obviously
you know how they do it be more kognito
be like alright you want to come at me
with the bull games I got that wallet we
gonna do certain games I like to give a
shout out to boxing last night we have
oh man you had a terrorist but Crawford
versus in dongle last night boxing was
lit last night we have one unified
champion shout out to Terence Byrd
Crawford for that left hook to the body
it was a thing of beauty like it was so
beautiful that that happened a combat
sports this year is is is that the
all-time high and we got we got Conor
McGregor voices I want to want to say
something real quick oh I just want to
say everybody that's like you know like
in a chat and everything like because I
know we live right now but please please
humbly just asking please support me on
that cuz I fly out on to Vegas next week
to do the entire coverage where
everything so I will have me whether a
McGregor on the show please before you
fly out the belt man you gotta let them
hold the base
start off with your the group habit and
July NPD's are in and the Nintendo
switch has one NPD for July 2017 as well
as arm splatoon - as the number one game
also was kind of interesting was that in
the top ten
yes platoon - at one we had Legend of
Zelda breath through the wild at five
and we had Mario Kart at seven so when I
bring this topic to the round table the
Lord's as far as arms allows NPD what do
we feel about that and I want to
actually start with hip hop because I
don't know if hip hop this switch gang
on this nah well for me I'm a gamer gang
dog like all I do is I am the game
industry like you understand I got way
more games any other journalists in this
industry I got over 20,000 games and
hundred thousand more coming all right
emulators are not whatever people say
what they want I got it all before
yo let me just see I can understand like
I ain't playing I like like look at my
like I got a 75 inch vizio p-series this
is the only 4k TV on the market that's
240 hours of fresh way is it better than
the Samsung q7f is better than a Sony 81
ready for my if you really want to keep
it again I said I got the 80 inch q9
though like I could get a shot there's
like 88 inches but it's little it's not
just about the size the shop at ghost is
an embarrassment in my opinion is I have
a partnership with B&H Photo Store so
these Cindy TVs they send me computers I
get a chance to swap out and switch and
do whatever I want
you don't saying so while trying to
explain to y'all is I get a chance to
test out everything and I wait for CES
lockers test out the new 2018 joys of
everything and I'm telling you when
you're playing like for example um I got
a CPU that's coming they got two GeForce
GTX 280s in it you already know what 4k
62 yeah keep talking about what's cuz as
a gamer an FPS guy I need to know that
input lag situation because that is all
for me
let me let me explain something over
this hole imple acting like a lot of
this stuff be like blown out of
proportion like a i'ma tell you what
like so with this particular TV I don't
know what the input lag is on the top of
my head play I could play the game it
feel great it feel smooth it's popping
now I'm a proof set notes I've been the
tournament's where I will play on a big
Q TV they got like the crazy crazy
refresh rate in terms of on the response
time but then I could go home and play
on my TV with the post-processing
on so that the smoothness is right so
you don't get their whack ass blur
missing when you turn around it still
have a great time so what you have to
understand is this if you have sixteen
point six six in s yeah you could go to
you go to vsync calm or you go abroad
Buster's calm it really touched your TV
out as long as you have a consistent
frame timing you always have a game that
feels great and responsive and you could
do damage the only time you're gonna
have input lag is when you have bad
frame timing because frame timing
creates an inconsistency of the feel of
the game and that's not the case now in
reference to the frame timing that you
mentioned like um is that uh what's the
word I'm looking for is that a trackable
statistic when comparing as two newer
TVs
I track it and you know saying so you
know like a lot of people in the hood a
lot of people in the game industry don't
think so now anyway back to the question
about the Swiss games I play everything
dog I don't care what it is if it's a
game give it to me I play you know I'm
playing a whole bunch of rolling sky
I don't care what it is and I'll write
anyway what I will say what I've been
playing on lately
men 18 is one of the best football games
ever made period so yes because takes
Madden NFL as a franchise in a whole new
direction just the story mode alone I
never felt anything went mad and before
that will possibly make a person want to
cry like the game is that great the
actors come on many and often at joint
so this game is amazing man it's amazing
and I see where they're going with it
the gameplay everything is amazing I
just wish that what you experience in a
story that same level of energy and care
was put into the regular game from a
presentation standpoint but other than
that the game is incredible way better
than last year's so the props the Rex
and everybody for the jump for
year-over-year jump they did a hell of a
job that's one so on top of Madden me
playing that game agents of mayhem is
the most underrated game I'm gonna tell
you how great ages to make let me ask
you a question
agent of mayhem is the reason why
crackdown 3 got delayed Real Talk
Microsoft will probably never admit to
that but I believe so yeah I believe so
wholeheartedly ageism an ass lawless do
you they gave it saying there's
absolutely nothing wrong with this game
at all from from the graphics to the
game played the gunplay the uniqueness
and story the uniqueness in each
character how you can build up your
Aegis edit them or in terms of your
squad all the abilities that unique to
the personality so that's what a lot
about the gaming like though based off
the personality you could tell that the
abilities that they chose the give the
action characters relate to how their
personality is Nasser is deep as deep as
deep as crazy as the open world all of
that you could drive it you do anything
is crazy but the reason why I'm so hyped
about ages of man
is because to me it's like how Jay Cohen
was able to go platinum without no
features like ageism mayhem to me is one
of those games that I was able to
dominate and it didn't even have a big
marketing budget this one situation
where they don't matter what I'm talking
tonight the moment you playing you know
I'm the truth that's how great age the
man is so I've been playing agent Madden
and it shows of my throw back um I
played a little bit of x-men shows
another atom okay no doubt I'm gonna
bring it back real quick because I know
we were left a little bit but I want to
bring it back to again in July and
pretty I know you got everything
okay the switch in its success and it's
beating the ps4 right now in terms of
the sales when it has stock do you think
this is going to continue and another
question I have in reference to November
that's a big month right we have the
Xbox one next drop in right no Nintendo
will have Mario Sony's gonna have the
crazy bundles you know I mean with this
exclusive third party its marketing
deals
let's drop the sole but the combination
about the switch you think it's gonna do
that and also what your reaction is now
that is actually okay so the with the
whole switch like notice the oxide self
you would sound none of this stuff is
impressive at the port at this point it
hasn't even been a full year yet your
listen I'm saying it's not is not fully
impressive at the moment alright like
Nintendo switch what's happening it's
supposed to happen this is no surprise I
told my Nintendo it they got like this
year this time around the marketing was
way better so people understood was
going on they had the the killer app in
terms of Legend of Zelda on was
incredible arms is dope I love arms that
game is fun Mario Kart is out so that's
the collab and you got maryada see to
look forward to at the end of the year
and it's a decent on and it's a decent
price for what you get and it's the only
system that you could take with you you
know saying so they have a lot of things
going for them but at the same time what
I tell people like let's have this
conversation like how long oh it's 2017
this has conversation because it a 19
okay
I'm saying it well saying is this right
when um when uh if you look at this
let's look at it for how is really
happening like I love dissecting [ __ ]
okay so here's the deal if you're
looking it's in the switch right if you
look at at the Wii U a comparison like
they're similar it so somehow they
started you like Nintendo switch but
they're not doing that much different in
terms of the impact that they had it was
of the initial time frame that it came
out you understand those they didn't so
that's the first thing and then the
second thing is oh you got the Xbox one
X coming out later this year so you got
an effect that that in cuz that's gonna
be the next new thing penis for is gonna
be dropping price soon and you got all
these other games is coming out in terms
of Call of Duty destiny is switch switch
you understand they're saying so my
thing is what's happening now it's
exciting it is good for the switch but
it's not so different from in terms of
parity between what we saw with the Wii
U when they first came out and did they
think so my people is trying to over
hype it because they don't want to see
the Wii U repeat itself with the switch
so they trying to do the damage control
you don't have to Nintendo's always
gonna be I they print money they good
and they're not trying to directly
compete with a Playstation or whatever
they have they own or they have the old
world that they living in and they're
doing good but talk to me in 2019 yes
yeah where we can see what it's like
year-over-year if you over here they
have significant growth in a certain to
talk about ok so right now saying is
like we need to see them at least passed
the Wii U before we talk thank you
open the gun and you know what it's like
you know this is what it's like it's
like somebody that comes out with Apple
right they have a great first week sales
and they feel like this [ __ ] gonna pop
off for the rest of their life like
people just got a chill the problem is
sometimes it's just like no man Scott no
man's sky was a game they had all this
hype but the height was bigger than the
actual game itself in height hurt them
more than help them in the long run so
let Nintendo do nitin though don't start
talking about a they're passing ps4 you
kiss talk abut New York it even speak of
PlayStation at this point and under the
league but when the movie started
mentioning Sony and Nintendo or the same
sentence right now you know what's gonna
happen Playstations gonna be late also
you thought you was actually competing
with me okay watch this
come on Nintendo yeah be smart about
this so look law your father's looking
at the long term let me get the rest of
the lords in right quick Oh Lord you
know anybody can jump in was everything
you know they do have hot going into
they got Mario Odyssey coming up here
soon rabbits comes out the week after
next you know they do they still off you
know the arms they're still off the the
Mario Kart I mean there are stuff to buy
on this which regardless but people say
but you know I do have the the same
thing that you know Lord hip-hop says
it's just like you know we see them
having a lot of support for the brand as
of right now the product and you know
it's looking like they have a lot of
support going in the future
but it's like you know you told me this
with the Wii U - and you stopped that at
two three years in so I got to see I got
to see more of their overall plan in a
long run that's when I start saying if
they're gonna be an overall what do you
feel about this uh July MPD results in
this which I mean I agree that people
generally tend to like jump the gun on
being super excited about the system but
I will say this to kind of differentiate
a little bit I just think that the talk
around us
and people's perception of the switch is
a lot more positive than the then then
the we you even at launch site we you
three fax three months three months into
the life of the we you people were
really sick about like the gamepad not
being super responsive the resolution on
the gamepad there were things about it
even before the system came out the
biggest thing more negative on the
biggest thing that helps to switch over
the the Wii U pad it's like you know
portability brilli really helps but it's
the overall and aesthetics like the put
the if if this would've came out last
year with that wouldn't be awkward in my
hand even if that was yeah that's not a
it wasn't on the toilet and even then
you start to break up so yeah I hit that
like button
it's low something sorry so I mean
honestly I think if the systems are out
there you see what they do they drop
systems close to the releases of their
big games did if possible attune they're
gonna do it for Mario rabid damn sure
they're gonna do it for a Mario Odyssey
so you're gonna see the system so if
they have systems in a while I think
they're gonna be winning MPD straight
through you so you're making is like the
supply I should be a if they have supply
room I think it's a supply because again
is I like if I said I get like the x1 X
is gonna be the new hot thing in
November but it's also $500 that's not
everybody's buying neces if the switch
is out there and you have a choice and
you already have like is it I would say
is the host a there's two things see
like in the
ministry you gotta understand how it
relates to the tech industry so with all
these people that spending money life
for example when when Black Friday come
and everybody's buying 4k TVs fit the
inches for like three hundred forty
dollars plea buying it because they want
to play xbox one X and PlayStation 4 Pro
on them by you know not because they
want to play the switch from a business
standpoint
you gotta also understand the relation
or why people buy this and the reason
why they buy this is so they could have
the Xbox one X in PC and ps4 pull at the
highest possible um you know like system
that they could play it on in terms of
TV and setups and things of that nature
switch doesn't like live in that
category because that's not what they're
trying to be so I'm not saying it's
gonna stop their sales they still gonna
sell but when that Xbox one eggs
dropping it is the new thing like people
are saving up money to get the best
possible experience they can like when
it dates okay dropping and when you have
WWE 2k drop and like all just in the
fall there's a lot of heavy hitters
that's not coming to switch switch got
Mario and that's good but as much as we
love Mario you understand the kids
growing up nowadays they're not grown up
or for Mario they're growing up of Call
of Duty they're growing up on for
destiny they've grown up on for these
games
so in tendo's trying to cater to an
audience that no longer caters like yes
I think it reflects I'm totally
different not to cut you off
yeah I I feel the mp3 MPD's show you
that there's a clear vision in Nintendo
now opposer to Wii U I have a Wii U it
was cumbersome it was last gen when it
came out this is still last gen as far
as the tech goals but it's sad about it
you understand like you
sitting there two controllers the value
in the package is what people are seeing
and as long as it's available it's gonna
sell I think it if it's available every
month it will outsell all of them every
month especially the Xbox one engine
even though we will be in the minority
as for okay you sold your television 4k
people was like oh my god yeah but they
still have that 1080p television and it
already is a critical mass point where
price vs. value equates I can go to the
store and purchase it's not gonna beat
it you don't even need a television for
the switch mmm you can just go in and
purchase a switch came on when you do
purchase a television a regular smuggler
you know it on it and you get your game
on
I do I do
MPD's showed that Nintendo has a clear
vision where the vision with the Wii U
was muddled it was muddled it was
convoluted the same way with Xbox
remember they're muddled and convoluted
stuff had them stumble and fall back
we're gonna get into that too right this
is the fact that this is like a
PlayStation type of thing very clear
very concise what about the games about
this they said we're about the
Portability and the games we're not
about 4k you can jump in anybody so on
the goal here you go to people it shows
the value that's why it's selling it's
not something for anything other than
value for price of dollar Lordi going to
jump in real quick
I feel like who's gonna win November is
gonna come on Black Friday I feel like
if Nintendo doesn't have the stock by
the end of that month they're not
winning that month there I mean I'm
hoping that you know they take Black
Friday serious and give like two
shipments to every retail that they
could possibly think of but this is
Nintendo we're talking about I don't
know if they're actually having legit
stalking issues or they're you
they're trying to give that you know
bait-and-switch thing oh we we don't
have much fight when you do see it so
you know that now look Xbox one X is
going to be the new it's gonna be the
new tech on the market on that November
it is you know if you look at it from
perspective of every potential person
who bought the original Xbox one for
five hundred dollars is a potential to
go buy it again because that's your
heart or base for the Microsoft brand
them are probably repeat customers and
it's sold like what 2.5 million the
first month so I mean obviously you're
not gonna get to five 2.5 million again
that's absurd but I wouldn't be
surprised if you get at least half of
them by the console again you say you
sit wait I just want to get this correct
so you you think that Nintendo is gonna
I'll sell everybody in America for the
rest of the year because you feel that
knows when I'll sell all of them you
know in the APD's you know throughout so
in my mind I just wanted to make sure
you do what you say we're gonna create a
segment called bended knee and the
second is it all in fun there's no
disrespect it's all if I'm basically
what it is is November we know is a big
month right so let's debut bend the knee
right now yeah all the people and all
the lords at the roundtable including on
hip hop who feel you know saying that
either who's gonna win MPB in November
whether it be Xbox Nintendo Sony you
know name so my thing is I feel if
Nintendo has the stock in that Mario
which drops at October 27 which is
technically November right it's the last
right
Dave so that means if I have the stamp
they have Mario available I don't even
think they need to bundle it because at
the end of the day I know people who
with you here here - I need you right
now
IOP bet baby who who you feel is winning
that November November I really believe
that and win it just because they're
gonna have the biggest marketing hype
around their entire franchise and the
entire brand for you know this year and
um you know in terms of you know history
every system that has had that type of
hype around it since because of
excitement has dominated you know like
that muff so strategically if you're a
betting person I think you were bet on
xbox for the November money if you look
like that's what I would say I'm not
saying Xbox 1x like that because it
comes out on the seventh so I'm saying
Xbox like the brakes but it's not so I'm
also always box but only issue my only
issue is that because destiny is coming
out and I'll call duties coming out Sony
and Sony has those partnerships mm-hmm
and those bundles in that white
PlayStation 4 all the hard right
[Music]
the only reason or the reason but the
reason why ultimately I will go November
because I feel like a few only saving a
money to put most of their money into
the Xbox because the combination of
Black Friday 4k TVs Xbox one X and
honestly honestly like when you see some
games you see these two days ago right
now we go revisit we go revisit in
November you know they like I said we
have a fun low seven or we go find out
because obviously we behind a little bit
and we got a lot of topics to cover and
it's a late show so um I'm gonna get in
a far city for the destiny to edge
information I'll get into that next week
y'all don't worry we gonna leave there's
a Destiny's always hit but I want to
give it to the Lord addict
gotta talk some crackdown yeah aftermath
let's talk to me Lord addict what's
going on
so as of you guys know crackdown got
delay you know there's a lot of
speculation that it's following the same
path
you know scalebound thought followed
before I got canceled so what I want to
know your overall thoughts on crackdown
being delayed and if you guys think it's
actually then he could cancel or do you
guys think that it was legit Lee just a
later the announcement that it was
canceled just got delayed anybody can
jump in y'all keep it on it like the
behind the scenes like a lot of people
wasn't feeling tracked down and there's
a lot riding on this game from a
financial standpoint so what they're
trying to do is we re create new hype
and new stuff so the next time you see
crackdown I believe you gotta see Terry
Crews character fully in it you're gonna
see like maybe steam to get people hype
all over again so that they can feel
good about spending his money now what
Microsoft and everybody on it has to
understand which I know they understand
is that there's so many other great
games on the market at all times
throughout the year that as good as your
game is or might be nobody needed I
could go so many places to get great
games so that means that is more
detrimental now for your game to be
successful and have social media type i
but you want your games
SARP memes it's stuff like that like you
don't say you watch a game to really
create cult following like you know
saying I'm saying I'm sorry you don't
want your game to into following mass
effect where it's dead before it comes
out because of memes cool factor is
everything cofactor like look when I
just buzz 360 came out and they had to
connect a lot of people didn't even use
mmm-hmm so I'll connect
or Oprah all right you still connect on
Ellen like it was so cool to have that
everybody wanted it even if they didn't
know why he wanted it they just want to
have it so they didn't feel left out of
the conversation you understand so I
feel like they're gonna do that and Ted
Cruz is gonna have a big part of the
marketing so that's why they had come on
you know it's serious when you got
people who tweet and out saying all of
these while people are giving this game
even half of a team you say well the Ted
Cruz tweeted back saying
so what buy it [ __ ] got to the point
where that type of stuff is happening
come on man you got a beat here so it
got delayed because of a lot of things
they was gonna get your whole invest
they would have went down the toilet
they were released it now they gotta in
the destruction listen your first
impression you you can't you'd never get
a second chance at a first impression
you fill me and all their first
impressions it has not been great so
they have to recreate the first
impression by show you something that
was so unexpected from the game I will
make you go from one extreme to another
answers of your thought towards it
Thanks hi I'm a jump in right quick I
mean I agree with a lot what Lord
hip-hop is saying I think um yeah I
think the first initial pressures of the
game were not good there was no solid
you know I personally was not impressed
I did not like the animation of the
character when his feet were actually
running on the floor I pointed out to
mojo 3 you know to mean no disrespect it
looked at like an upraised version of
the older titles I didn't dream anything
the next Jimmy there was nothing that
said you know this is why I need to buy
the system not saying it wasn't gonna be
fun kind of thing and then like you said
like a hockey
thing was when they debuted this thing a
while back they talked about full
destruction
and the fact it was so secretive they
wouldn't show anything on it and you
know shout the lobby money and stuff a
couple other people can take you were
like no ready and to be honest not if
the news came out more attic what's your
topic I'm happy it got delayed because
at the end of the day even if crackdown
was the hottest thing on the street even
if it was great you're putting it out
knows about November 7th you're putting
out between Assassin's Creed and Call of
Duty dad I'm telling you to die it would
have been all too positive situation it
would have been a titanfall to situation
so ultimately let that thing survive
into 2018 when it has a window to itself
as a month to itself maybe they can
polish up begin do what they got to do
here's the problem though here's the
problem sir in 2018 my right off the
back they bought they hit you with god
of war too much man I understand you
know in my personal opinion I'd rather
compete against god of war days gone on
another platform than competing big
triple-a titles that's also on my
platform we said this a couple of shows
ago we we out like we cried for it to
happen we said Microsoft don't put this
game out we said I know you listen to
Mikey better shout out the hood and Phil
We Trust talk to you on the side you
asked my impressions on stuff listen
when I was there I wasn't overwhelmed by
the game felt like a remastered they
took the temperature of the room they
had a closed environment where gamers
were able to sit down and play they
check
the enthusiasm on each game if you were
ranking your game from one to ten it
came at an eleven it came out of the
pack it wasn't and even in the bunch
people weren't sitting down playing it
they looked at it initially I touched my
curiosity got the best me
look our needles curiosity was not
touching and even on 10 10 80s and you
know because it wasn't running off the
system and they were running off for 10
80s off the PC listen the game had
serious problems
no destructibility push it back let the
game breathe in a spring we've noticed
that games in the springtime seem to
thrive they give it a little bit more
legs I honestly believe just like Lord
hip-hop just said hey huh it came it was
like oh my god they pop that disc in
they say yo I'll push that back push
that back I think it's just that
fatalist mentality because I I
completely agree that the game had no
business coming out November November is
reserved for certain Fassett games a
certain game did all the duty destiny
exactly battle still you know certain
games can survive it's like you know
what you can have that november/december
just to be on the safe side I don't want
to be around any of that I don't want to
be around any of that crap I don't care
how great it would have looked it was it
does not belong there period right what
happens is and once it gets delayed then
you have some people with this fatalist
mentality like Oh Xbox one X has nothing
now and going back ridiculous that go
back to what hip-hop said it would have
gotten drowned out anyway like for
somebody to say listen that's the only
thing I was looking forward to and now
I'm not buying an X that doesn't make
any sense to me like there's so much
other stuff
look better on the X and we sort of
agreed Assassin's Creed Wolfenstein
Mordor all this stuff show off your
system with this the only chance this
game had to survive is to get kicked out
of November and pushed back because at
the end of the day a bad game is bad
forever
a delayed game with a delay can only get
better can only get better and the fact
of the matter is there one thing that
Microsoft I don't think could really
have a survive I mean it would survive
it but it's been hard is to drop another
subpar game something in the vein like a
quantum break or something it was not
you know it's not exactly what people
wanted I love that game - I love aspects
of that game but to me I'm thinking of
the ads that's a remedy game that's max
payne max payne runs circles around the
suit in that game I think when Xbox one
X comes out and I get that ball in that
resolution we talked about recall we're
gonna get a definitive edition of recall
where it's gonna be finally finished
it's gonna be 4k so like yeah I'm gonna
just keep it a buck so nobody no kid
like me personally man I really feel
that Xbox they damn it like verse 360
right mm-hmm
like you had Xbox laughs which was
amazing and there was excitement around
it you actually had exclusives I don't
mean play anywhere I mean actually
exclusives like dil is this culture of
our Xbox just like how PlayStation got a
culture around them PlayStation nation
and it's Indo even now we got a coach a
switch game like they create like Xbox
is this so to me I really really feel
that at this point
no matter what Xbox do it's not about
how much power they got actually it's
not even about having certain games
because I could play all their games
somewhere else
all of them you're saying I think their
biggest issue is they have poor
messaging when relationship mmm with
their any user they have literally no
Xbox gave their customer service their
customers herpes touch on another topic
and I want you to hold that door for a
second literally are hitting their head
and also on something that won't work on
pole two but all okay a lot of people
are you know really skeptical when it
comes to crackdown getting delayed you
know it's it's like Lord sovereign said
like anyone who's saying ain't gonna
pick up an X because that's crackdown
got delayed they were not picking up an
X anyway I think this is good for the
franchise itself I think it's good for
multiple reasons I don't know I think
it's good because you're getting away
from that November colony title it's
like you know what a lord hip-hop said
they are competing with you know Sony's
exclusives but you know it's on two
different platforms and it's not a
battlefront two weeks later and that's
asses Creed a week before that a Call of
Duty a week after that and one thing
that I do is by the time I think this is
good for the crackdown franchise itself
because as of right now crackdown is the
game that's like if it doesn't make the
exfil worth it it's on done but by the
time this this game comes out the the
Haight fruit X is gonna be over so
crackdown will literally be able to
stand up be like oh I don't have this I
don't have to ride the X I could
literally just be a game wasn't even in
my purchase category as far as all the
stuff
that we're coming out I told y'all
already Assassin's Creed is a 1 on the
list
listen look I got footage of Assassin's
Creed that I'm a release I gotta figure
I wouldn't know but embargo is I think
an August 24th okay I can't wait bro we
got the gamescom conference or at us at
3 so we got yeah we got there was all
phases classic saw would you mind if we
skip all the games come a little bit
because of the fact that we're gonna
actually talk about it and go or you
want to jump really quick predictions
right before the show starts oh yeah
that's fine all right no doubt um I'm
gonna jump in says law hip hop touched
on this I want to expand on what he
talked about and I wanted to bring into
a topic to the roundtable basically what
he kind of expounded on so right now a
lot of people are going down the saying
that 2017 it's like xbox right now now
what I would have rigged it around and
oh I had like four years yeah 2017 with
the lack of exclusives in the fiasco
right I want you to compare this versus
2013 which was the Xbox one reveal the
mixed messaging that you know DRM that
whole stuff so that was a good load on
it did you do the dog magic you go bring
it to the road say in your opinion the
year of the L which is the worst year
Lord hip-hop and bring it back to you
since you started this subject
um I would say this is the worst year
movies watch day this is where she is
because in 2013 he was just coming out
all of a sudden took place you would
think that they have learned a lot and
which they have first mr. has done a
much better job in biometric building
things back up but the problem is in the
process of building up they still be
taking steps back making the same
mistakes so you in in business in life
with people you have smart people and
you got wise people you got people that
smart that make dumb mistakes like your
Xbox is in a situation where mistakes
from playing a game where they sacrifice
nothing is like you so my thing is if
you learn a lot so to me like this is
worse because they knew better and too
many they made too many mistakes for
them to be who they are that's like
that's like that's like if Michael
Jordan turn the ball over three times
which gave him three rings instead of
six you Michael Jordan certain mistakes
you don't make like you don't say if you
try to be the goal Xbox but they
experienced they came out 2001 homie
come on man then certain people aren't
allowed to have certain excuses God you
so even even though I him I was gonna
bring it back to you one time so even
with the whole DRM fiasco the use games
the you know we have at 360 you know
that to you is worse because you knew
better
that is alligator right here they
shouldn't know what they were dealing
with right now and your mentality is
what is going on because you know what
you're dealing with
look out Sonia from Sony learned so much
for ps3 their peers for us all bring to
being their best system ever even over
ps2 cuz they learned miss Botz
Xbox one was their learning process
where's the redemption ladies they for
the deep-ando Nintendo they learned
often with you mm-hmm
there's just a better general energy
around it it was a positive talk come on
man you gotta learn I want to get the
lords in this lord King this generation
Microsoft is the meek Millz of this
video he posted the other day or some
other stuff Microsoft down today way no
matter how right they they try to go
something always goes left no matter
what this is the right move was to put
out this system but the message in was a
little off uncompromised will pull
uncompromising to print in the caption
what they said was the best 4k
experience
is the strongest in a position by seeing
uncompromised oniy is the Drake it is in
a beginning you know somebody's writing
his stuff nobody drop this joint
nobody's listening bro
what are you saying we oughta meet meals
a whole is L you understand got it we
got it we got to get it together we
gotta hold itself this system is gonna
come out
this system is gonna do what its gonna
do make sure your messaging is clear
don't look like you lyin to the public
don't look like you're trying to mislead
the public the best thing that they did
was move crackdown they heard you say no
that ain't it bro
and so instead of taking the L they
getting them out of there so just like
Lord hip-hop said they need to learn
remember this is Phil's learning process
that s was a removal of Don matrix ugly
system so the regime change
right the s fix that we gotta understand
it was a regime change there was no real
regime change it Sony there was just a
constant machine pushing fully actually
mimics a lot of what the 360 days so
they learn from that era you know
in this war 50 loss of power 15 loss of
power they used it yeah Microsoft is
using now is remember they if their step
behind because is a regime change
there's a whole different philosophy
it's no longer TV TV TV TV it's about
power it's about taking back control
so what Phil is doing is you know he
didn't like what scalebound look like
come on everybody tell the truth man
still had stutters it was going there's
no game on the market right now that was
quite like that so it would have been a
great look for wants to have something
like that it would have been a clear-cut
differentiator of like Sony like sorry
got so much variety that you just
[Music]
imagine for every ever you come over do
from the VR to all Lubich planet in
dreams and [ __ ] silly guy all right they
got too much different stuff that you
just never seen before the diverse
portfolio def stranded coming spider-man
coming got a war coming
daddy's dog coming I'll slap myself just
a dream son it'll make no sense and this
is like this is like somebody poured
soul emanated titty juice we were saying
all of this right if right Microsoft's
message was right in the beginning cuz
remember everybody destroy Sony there
would be no Dave gone it days will be
gone because microsoft word came out and
they would it did what they supposed to
do but we have EDS and flows and just
like Lord sovereign said last episode I
believe these news is in cahoots
we we we do not subscribe to the
philosophy at LP but I'm telling you
you can pre-order the X at the Microsoft
Store right now yeah be honest man and
I'm gonna tell you guys I'm with you on
that one facts 2013 the messaging coming
out of Xbox this is the whole company
saying yeah this is what we're gonna do
DRM we're gonna be watching you all the
time forget about to use games like this
was the company line coming out of there
people didn't agree with that line but
again when that's what it is so to me
the fact that they were trying to come I
think I think that was just that was
egregious to me that was really
egregious to me now when you look at
2017 like the thing the thing is that we
keep notice about with Xbox and the
PlayStation is that Xbox doesn't get
away with what PlayStation came maybe
and maybe that's a condition come on on
any of you pocket maybe that's a
condition of you being a second place
cuz Sony can get away with funky
marketing lying about specific things
that their systems can and can't do or
giving colorful colorful descriptions
about what the system's can it can't do
because their first place they get away
with that
in second place you can't really get
away with that cuz you're gonna get
scrutinized let's be honest if you look
at everything that Phil's trying to do
with Xbox you know again impasse with
that compact with the prices dropping
when I'm play anywhere like there's a
lot of positivity around the only thing
that just gets superseded in Australian
we found consumer this whole general
exactly they've been absolutely
pro-consumer so what
are they taking an L anyway yes
absolutely can't really say they're not
taking an L anyway but the fact of the
matter is that that the intention is not
that is not there the intention to not
do well by the consumer isn't there
whereas in 2013 that's the way it felt
like that was hubris and you're gonna
eat this and that's that I mean I'll
jump in like quick - I mean I feel that
you know when was Don Mattrick jumping
at stage there was a whole bunch of TV
TV TV NFL connect and then shout-out to
the chat cuz the chat is on it with
corny old mr. kerosene like I'll never
forget to me the most bit moment is when
you had your schita and numb and saying
okay this is how we trade use gangs it
was over at that point that was when he
hit when they hit Microsoft with the
back-to-back drinks all they had such a
PR hit and negativity and like walking
me and you talked about this make no
mistake if we remember that day like it
was yesterday
press conference got delayed like an
hour before and that was and they said
it they say we got a can we removed the
DRM can we remove the camera they looked
at all the mistakes Microsoft made and
they got that out of there had the small
price so you had the cheaper system
didn't have the deal he had the public
behind them now it's a little bit more
powerful right with the GTR was it the
same exact system - the RAM and stuff
like that right mail or card needlenose
Ned they push back as delete
documentation though the white paper
came out that all that stuff in it and
that's why when you booted up your
system for the first time it took you 20
hours is that to me because of that
culture because that energy and people
were so angry at Xbox that it to this
day they are still doing a miracle but
they're still in recovery mode when
they're old took over so to me this is
just yeah I'm not sayin teen I'm not
minimizing 2017 is not a good look from
an exclusive standpoint you're
completely right I won't take that away
all I'm saying is that I think we got
Ned here because of 2030 not just my
feeling on it but Lord addict I want to
get you in and we'll give it back to
hip-hop I feel like it has to be 2013
the only reason I say that 2017 might be
bad because you know we've had very few
retail games but I feel like out of the
overall what was worse for Xbox who was
the reason we're where we are now
because if they would have came out and
you know that Xbox launched how it
should have launched without that reveal
just the e3 and a better reveal who
knows what would be happening you know
the the height would have been towards
Xbox you know because they at the end of
the you know last generation it was it
was about even you know they both had
pretty good hype going into the next-gen
and it's like I said multiple times you
know I feel like Sony has a lot to thank
for their domination this generation for
the Last of Us ending with the Last of
Us and Microsoft didn't really end with
anything spectacular and destiny picking
of destiny at the beginning of the
generation when I was huge and you know
coming into 2013 Microsoft dropped the
ball so much they it was it was
unrecoverable you know let's say that
they came out did everything and you
know they were doing really good
you know the let's say maybe Microsoft
wouldn't be winning you know MPD's or
anything like that but it was closer it
was more you know it was so you know the
brain would be more faithful George Xbox
and we could be hitting games in 2017 if
2013 went different I feel or I hit
probably will let you respond to what we
said real quick if you still yeah I seen
you in the whip stunt no no my bad I'm
so sorry
now see what happened is um refund I
cool so what happen is I just want to
give a shout out to my boy Donnie Donnie
was he was in a coma um last year and he
came out as coma
he beat cancer and um he's a hardcore
gamer he's actually a fan of mine and I
made a video on last year's to tell him
to get well and get better and we gonna
play games and I'm gonna see you soon
and Lord allowed him to live another day
and be with us
so I'm off to go drop off a whole bunch
of video games to him take some pictures
and stuff like that so that's all I do
gotta get ready and go because because I
have to uh follow the GPS on my phone
play why I just want to thank y'all for
having me on here and I think that after
Gamescom we should all probably do like
a follow-up tonight on tonight okay just
have a follow-up to you know what took
place at Gamescom I just finished up
this show cuz the failures deserve a
finish show and I and I still had some
other stuff to say based on what I just
said so I gotta see you before you fly
out the Vegas so me you're gonna link
I'm hit you off for some stuff what you
doing for your boy we definitely will
revisit don't name we're about you could
jump out if you got to you know mean
don't even worry about it man honestly
I'm so sorry about that
so the God bless you guys and um they
also just to give you a little heads up
I'm working on some important stuff for
the later part of the gear gentle would
be an h2 launch the next year so um just
a tool man I have this big New York City
take over there i won
do with a lot of you know a lot of us
cuz I want people to see this light you
don't say we don't only play a to ki we
don't live in a major way and all you
know just laughing help me out with that
so we're gonna talk soon a whole new
bond of things right we're continually
just finish it real quick another hip
hop's got a roll out um I just wanted to
go sis we'll do a part two King and all
saw will save will save what you the
game some stuff will do that post like
we can do yeah just real quick of what
we think you know could possibly come to
games cause let's give it back to solved
in gays calm predictions on that and
actually well I got I'm sorry I have to
interrupt for five seconds I'll go for
Itachi Uchiha
you my man okay that's my that's my dude
to tell you appreciate everybody say
that like button on real quick actually
forgot on the last week poll results
real quick but we'll do all that solve
let's get into these games or Gamescom
predictions um what do we think it with
crackdown being delayed obviously that's
not gonna be a centerpiece of whatever
they talk about it game calm so what do
we think is coming how do they kind of
kind of soften the blow is there
anything secret of the secret that we
think might be talked about we haven't
heard about um so so my thinking just
just to jump right into it immediately
is that they need to lean into all the
games
third-party stuff that looks fantastic
on the system like we just talked about
statins Creed Wolfenstein Mordor they
need to really lean it lean into how
much better those games look on the x1 X
and what does it push that also they
need to lean meaning into um
cuphead and how great cuphead looks
hopefully they have some more stuff to
talk about they need to really lean in
to all the all the smaller indie stuff
that they showed at e3 that we got to
play on the show floor they're gonna
have to you know bring those games up
the battle chasers and all that other
stuff make that stuff really shine and
make you know again give give people the
impression that it looks and runs best
on their system and hopefully we don't
know how much of that stuff's coming out
this year so there were two to specific
leagues I know they wanted to announce
the project Scorpio edition and it's all
out in the streets now so that's not a
big surprise anymore that would have
been a nice thing but whatever they're
still announce it and get the reaction
to that to to specific leaks that I saw
that could be interesting there is
something called codename Hollywood
that's supposed to be there's no
indication what kind of game that is it
has like a placeholder release date for
2017 it's a farm you know so I mean that
could be an interesting thing if it's
actually is something real that they're
ready to show off that could be exciting
um another game that got leaked by a
German magazine and shout out to
Destructoid where I saw this a game from
THQ Nordic the same guys that are doing
the Darksiders games
it's called bio mutant and it's
basically like an open-world action RPG
again it's coming out for everybody but
again who knows if there's Microsoft
maybe has some kind of leaving like that
will be on this stage so again they need
to lean into what we already know and
give us reason like that X to purchase
that X you know yeah absolutely I mean
look I'm gonna be really choked I don't
want to get my hopes up you know I
noticed some leaks going on I've seen in
Minecraft system going on out there they
look pretty good obviously a lot of
people already know about this project
school up your audition I'm very excited
about that because I always loved that
name and I didn't like the Xbox one next
name so me personally if that is true
which it looks like it is you know I'm
height for that
I'm a glass I know Phil's not gonna beat
it I'm not saying he won't have anything
but I will say to Lord that explained in
Lord Aggie turning me
he's turning my mentality around cuz
he's like look man if they're telling us
to crack down announcement you know as
far as it being delayed if they're
telling that before the show that means
they most likely might have something
and it may be some truth to that kind of
like woody III mentality you get the mad
moves out first right and then when the
show jumps off you hit them with the
surprises and stuff like that so you
know there's a chance that that could
happen you know what I'm gonna keep it
very reserved you don't know me now
you know if shot a recording on the Chad
he's saying like if they do something
like pubsey exclusive oh yeah I'd the
trumpet Roble I would say hey that's the
goal absolutely half of G yes so we'll
see I mean not just my mentality on it
you know Lord King knows what adequate
yeah guys that with it
I think for some reason I've been
feeling crackdowns not gonna be a games
going oh no it's not gonna be I think
that's the real they they announced that
you know before pre-show because they
they know people are gonna ask wise and
Gamescom and then they're gonna
automatically assume it's been cancelled
this and that so I do think that's one
of the reasons I think we might get a
record to announcement because the
definitive de feel I'm talking about - I
think they might come out their show
trailer and sayin right now at the end
of this month you can get record the
definitive edition oh okay okay well I
mean besides that that's all I can
really think that they would announce
like I don't see anything huge huge I
hope they don't come out there and just
say you know you can you can you can
pre-order today oh and you can get the
SPECIAL Scorpio edition cat3 I hope they
don't do that Lord King what do you need
to see needs to be shown sorry dizzy see
if these needs to be shown they need to
show that rate cracking thing they keep
talking about Lucy okay alright so I
just think they're gonna show more the
same don't give you price point
pop G
they need to ride that wave if they're
smart ride that wave in I don't care if
it equates to a loss but um get that get
that game up and running and get people
excited about that game and that system
and let that be your pushing point um
going like Lord sovereign said on those
little games we wanted to know more
about like the PC gaming show showed us
more about like they took a more
intimate experience of it show more let
people see more of what we have to offer
I keep saying we'd like I don't have
multiple systems you know Microsoft or
because my blood is green without being
family so show show what you have to
offer lunch Amy so is his money so you
know that we have that's different
because Sony like Lord hip-hop was
saying the diversity is crazy but they
got a chance to cultivate that you know
this regime is it starting from square
one there's no cultivation here so a lot
of stuff from behind the scenes was
pushed to the edges and push to the side
Gamescom they said you know from III
wait to Gamescom so we're gonna get that
Age of Empires in debt we're gonna get
uh hope is play anyway I hope is on Xbox
Xbox out the Lord is in the chat he's
saying there's a lot of rumors hence
going on cliff he made some cryptic
Twitter tweets as far as lawbreakers for
your neck right now Lord king of the
chat he's like getting preview is going
deep yeah that's fantastic dizzy haha
anyway listen cliffy B and this is what
happens when you chase the bag you chase
the bagger you throw on your head the
bag didn't feel good right now the X is
coming down now you won't come back home
was open bring the game over here we're
gonna show you what a [ __ ] it did and
next time you don't go over there
chasing bags mmm so you feel if that is
the case you feel that cliffy B's
motivation is more because of the
failures they face you got a safe face
right now he looks like a fool because
he was talking all this crap about
overwatch and all these other game my
game is this and you your hubris bro
down the earth now right look at you you
flop you flop you went straight plastic
I do plastic so now let's [ __ ] your tail
let's tuck your tail let's get in that
Honda put the Ferrari back inside the
driveway he's gonna sell that game to
make up for the loss he made enough
talking all this how you talk about the
king throwing rocks at the throwing your
arms too short to box with God they
smacked you down that wasn't even paying
him your game with plastic section
coming out today would be tremendous yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
to say is you lucky I won in that part
in that podcast you back though with
that bit where
we got 12 we got 10 minutes y'all
it does not matter any kind of dill
meaning the word kognito had because
Garrity okay
radio and okay podcast alright so last
week all results in people spoken to the
question which franchises like titanfall
Mass Effect and pub G that were
initially exclusive to Xbox Microsoft
should develop their own first party
studios instead group they were the
winner at 55% strong and one of the most
intense high LP Twitter polls ever the
group said Microsoft should pay to keep
those exclusives finished up at a razor
close 45% so it was real hard fought
thanks to over damning 500-plus who
participated in the poll you don't say
anything I'll feed medicines with
when a salut thank y'all that it was a
lot of engagement we appreciate that
real quick one of the Lords think about
that people want Microsoft to develop
their own first party studios instead it
was close though you know I was I was
part of that Clara that crowd um we have
to build that culture if we don't build
that culture we're just gonna die out ya
know it's awful you feel about that with
results same thing I mean again there's
got to be a balance man invest in things
that you know will do well in your
system but you need to invest in your
own I mean we talked about the numbers
and stuff in the past how the numbers
don't necessarily match up with with our
first party exclusives but it's just
it's the differentiating thing you need
to have that it's just it doesn't matter
like it doesn't matter how much it sells
they need to have an identity and don't
in that regard so yeah definitely your
shelter going to chat we are doing games
called um Lourdes Lourdes attic what was
your feeling on the poll real quick I
feel like I'd love for them to go out
and make you know these these
extravagant studios and you know they
need to but people need to understand
even if they do this is not a process
that's done in five to ten years look
how long a super naughty dog to go it up
to the Colossus as it is acts look how
long it took dice look how long it said
bears most of the talent in this
industry is already employed by other
people so I want them to do it but at
the end of the day their best bet is to
you know do it slowly Mia maybe start
with one to two Studios but you know
give them a little bit to make some be
rated titles don't let them make us
because if you give them a triple a
title budget and they flop on the first
one studio gone yeah so they need to
build them up and you know they need to
it takes years you know they need to you
know this these people don't work out
well you got to go here's some more
people try these people I mean it took
Naughty Dog like 15 years they they
worked on what six games yeah not good
points alright yeah we got eight minutes
and when I wrap your sucked up we got
one more thing I want to talk about
which is the last thing is actually the
new poll for this week and on this one
was actually sought out to
Lord the Caffery this was inspired by
him and um I was watching an old xbox
bosses interview so this is gonna be a
regime in leadership question as far as
Xbox so whose model envisioned for Xbox
do we prefer the most multiple choice
question a the calm long term gain
vision and services approach of Phil
Spencer our Lord and Savior be the
aggressive III tattoos for exclusive
high budget spending Peter law or see
the big bucket budget marketing games
and hi TV and media approach of the god
and we got a conference news for 360 the
dollar himself
Patrick so that is the question those
are the choices please Rock the Vote hit
them ILP Twitter polls up I'm gonna try
to get that up during Gamescom or after
Gamescom most likely and uh like I said
thank you guys for voting for the last
Johnny so long I'm looking forward to
this one to see if everybody feels about
xbox leadership and the regimes and
where they feel that's going so on
yeah man please like I said your shout
out to everybody in the chat today or
subscribe I will say this in Lord Kings
defense fails fence is what I call he
was he had to adopt a [ __ ] child
that was given to him make it look
pretty
I say this and I defer the Godfather
quotes like Peter Moore because you in
wartime right now you need a wartime
consigliere
because you beat them all feeling that
that was our best time I was out winning
time but you know Phil hasn't had that
space that willing to brief but when he
shown you I will say this before we end
yes Spencer broadest he brought you that
box so Oh No thank everyone for our
debut on the unit circle Network for
listening
y'all was strong out here I'm like
overwhelmed by the love you know hit
that like that subscribe to the ILP on
all our media outlets in a circle you
too you know we still on iTunes and
SoundCloud we're in transition with that
but we still have that up so you can
still search for Ireland's podcasts on
that real quick we'll do our outro Lord
addict or brother from another mother
what you got going on oh no doubt boom
no sovereign what you know PSN and xbox
live Twitter Lord saw ILP talk later my
games come no doubt Lord King the
premium talk with hip-hop game you can
find me on the usual places all social
media um but this game is calm about to
happen
yeah we got three nice two games this is
more Cognito here we gave you that game
gonna shout out the hip-hop game was
still coming through despite all his
obligations we're gonna give you our
part to that stay tuned most likely
after the power I'll send out check out
the RP Twitter tonight power yeah I know
for the people that got the app they're
good but for others you know and people
are Game of Thrones people but no thank
you for our debut our hair showing us
support
we gonna get ready for Gamescom we'll
give you our impressions and add later
tonight as well and on that note we are
out peace